on on sort bien mieux de cette élection
législative surtout que des élections
présidentielles donc c'est effectivement
l'objectif fixé était d'avoir un groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale l'accord que
nous avions passé avec nos partenaires
le PS était était dans cette visée là
donc bien évidemment nous sommes
satisfaits ce soir d'avoir 19 députés
hein si le résultat reste comme cela
toute la soirée enfin
définitif un petit regret quand même en
sonéir c'est vrai que on a des
effectivement des femmes qui sont élues
à gauche et c'est très bien moi j'aurais
préféré qu'on ait un jeune élu
écologiste qui soit député en sonéloire
si au niveau de la sonéloire on avait pu
garder l'accord comme il avait été
convenu comme nous nous avons joué tout
à fait le jeu par ailleurs autre part en
Bourgogne notamment Côte d'Or vous avez
fait le gros dos sur ces situation là
finalement vous avez dû laisser passer
l'orage parce que vous n'avez pas
tellement d'autres solutions bah c'est
surtout que que l'enjeu là été
l'important c'était vraiment de de de
continuer d'avoir une
majorité parlementaire qui soit la même
que la majorité présidente
et bon maintenant on va travailler
ensemble et c'est vrai que moi c'est
voilà c'est un regret quand même et puis
et puis benah maintenant on va avancer
et faire avancer nos idées